good afternoon my name is jeff coday i'm
captain with the las vegas metropolitan
police department
we've asked you all here today to
announce our annual holiday initiative
it is the mission of the las vegas
metropolitan police department to
provide exceptional police services in
partnership with the community
we would like to thank the meadows mall
for partnering with us today for this
announcement
the purpose of the holiday initiative is
to prevent and reduce crime through in
increased police presence and targeted
enforcement at high traffic shopping
areas throughout the valley
this initiative will begin this week and
run through the holiday season
historically the friday following
thanksgiving
is noticed or
is known for being the busiest
shopping day of the year
and it also marks the beginning of the
christmas shopping season
while many businesses have adjusted
their practices in recent years we
anticipate a high volume of shoppers
on the roadways and in stores this year
that being said there's always a
criminal element that tries to take
advantage of this large increase in
choppers and retail activity
common crimes include robberies auto
burglaries and thefts
as part of this holiday initiative the
lvmpd will deploy marked vehicles
dedicated to proactively patrolling
these high shopping
high traffic shopping areas and
responding to any crimes in those areas
in addition there will be plain
out and about looking for people who may
be engaged in criminal activity
during the 2020 holiday initiative
officers conducted over 4 500 vehicle
stops and initiated over 1 500 person
stops officers also conducted over 336
arrests including 141 felony and gross
misdemeanor arrests
additionally officers impounded 13
firearms
although we will have additional
officers in these areas there are things
that shoppers can do to help decrease
their chances of becoming a victim this
year
first shop with a plan
prioritize your list and plan out your
day if you're going to make a high value
purchase such as a tv electronics or
jewelry
make sure you do not store those in your
vehicle in view of other people
if possible consider leaving small
children at home so they don't get lost
in the crowds
if children are with you have a
predetermined location to meet in case
you are separated also make sure
children have your phone number so that
they can reach you if you do become
separated
only bring with you credit cards that
you actually intend to use
for that trip
many financial institutions allow credit
card holders to receive notifications
regarding account activity
we would suggest that you investigate
this option
so that if your credit card becomes
compromised your account can be frozen
and prevent further unauthorized
transactions
do not let other people see you enter
your pin number be careful as you're
entering your pin number and know who's
around you
if you're using cash do not carelessly
handle cash
and show others around you how much you
have
do not leave purses phones or other
small electronic devices in your vehicle
in plain view
criminals may be in parking lots looking
for people loading items into their
vehicles and then walking back into
stores to make additional purchases
it only takes a few seconds for a
criminal to break a window and remove
those items from your vehicle
have a backup shop with a friend or
family member if possible
when shopping at night park in well-lit
areas near the main entrances if
possible
and as always be aware of your
surroundings
in closing we wish all of our residents
and visitors a happy holiday season
please make sure or help us keep the
community safe this year by reporting
suspicious activity as always if you see
something say something
thank you with that i'll be happy to
answer any
um how questions have you been doing
this initiative this isn't the first
time this initiative has gotten to
actually correct
no we we do this uh annually um it's
been at least uh
10 to 15 years now
what has been the success rate of this
in the past
traditionally this initiative does have
success
we
obviously the goal is to reduce crime in
these areas
during the during the holiday season and
typically we're successful at that
um
it does it does the purpose is to make
sure that we have officers that are
highly visible in those areas making
contact uh with
with those stores letting them know
they're there and obviously the the
increased visibility and presence we
want that to make sure obviously
criminals know that we're there to
hopefully avoid
avoid that can you talk about safety
inside the store and outside the store
where does that typically happen in the
parking lot
um it can really happen anywhere um
pickpockets bag thefts people um not
being attentive to their items they set
a bag down to make a purchase for
example or if they're at the at the food
court getting something to eat and they
set a bag down or they're not paying
attention and they leave their person
attended as well as in their car
a lot of time crimes are
they're crimes of opportunity so
it's not uncommon for
crimes to occur when people leave their
vehicle unattended or
again carelessly leaving
high value items you know sitting in the
front seat or in plain view
can you speak to the specific novelty of
dealing with shopping in vegas
in vegas
as far as
what makes us different in other cities
um
obviously we have a huge diversity in
shopping areas within the las vegas
valley
obviously a high volume of shopping
areas concentrated along the strip and
area
that part of the valley as well as all
our shopping areas throughout the valley
uh we also have a high volume of
tourists from all over the country all
over the world that come here so
um you know in that regard um it's kind
of unique but um but again we have uh
we have our officers in all of those
shopping areas again trying to make sure
everybody's safe
absolutely you know what and that's what
kind of what it boils down to be aware
of your surroundings
try to avoid letting others know what
items of value that you have and that
will go a long way toward
helping you
not become the victim of crime
all right thank you